si j'ai le manteau alba qui se présente
de cette façon avec des boutons qui sont
complètement factice à l'avant surtout
l'avait cité vient à l'arrière donc ce
manteau là a vraiment été développé pour
les personnes qui sont dans des
fauteuils très humblement comme le
fauteuil si vous voyez de mon frère je
pense qu'il faut tourner comme vous et
que c'est dur ce que vous faites
c'est pas quelque chose qui fait briller
mais c'est quelque chose je pense qu'il
est nécessaire à la société vous vous
ouvrez les yeux sur effectivement des
choses dont on n'a pas conscience vous
avez réussi à résoudre ce problème à le
positive et rendre le sourire à votre
frère à tous ceux qui vont enfiler vos
vêtements c'est extraordinaire
j'adore le jury complice effectivement
assez mal payé et c'est à moi qu'il ya
déjà une saison 2 qui est qui qui les
[Rires]
aggrave
il est dans l'air du temps il est
innovant et les français qui sont encore
en crise là vous venez on peut des
investisseurs viennent mettre de
l'argent et prennent des risques et
surtout ils ont réussi à garder de
l'émotion ça c'est l'arrêt ça plus
d'infos plusieurs millions d'euros ont
été investis grande part des
investissements c'est leur argent à m6
qui avait six et ils prennent le risque
celui d'avant mg / partie le magal et
moi j'ai adoré c'est forcément ce
programme je suis propres aux programmes
n'y a pas de problème par contre j'ai
une critique une seule que julien
courbet ça veut dire julien courbet pour
moi il est excellent c'est le meilleur
dans son domaine il n'a rien à [ __ ]
dans une émission où il est présent que
six minutes vous destinez misery à la
fin car oui par une affaire je trouve
que c'est sous-exploité julien courbet
carrousel ordinaire et quand on voit par
exemple david ginola dans la nouvelle
star je sais pas trop quoi là qui sert
strictement à rien alors programmes
connaissent et julien s'élaborait me
faut maintenant ce n'est pas parce que
quelqu'un sans aucun sens dans son
émission l'huile un vrai sens dans cette
émission et on le voit que six petites
minutes une volonté de sa part de ces
risques
alors bien sûr il est producteur julien
est un grand pro il est producteur
d'émissions si je me trompe pas vrai je
pense que il est producteur c'est sony
qui est producteur de l'émission il
vendredi contre les piqûres abbaoui
producteur exécutif et parfois j'ai des
côtés guy maxime guinée après ça
pourtant d'abord une action sera
programme comme ça la france est le 40e
pays à mettre à l'antenne ce format est
sûre les entrepreneurs et en allant
chercher beaucoup 700 au départ 60 ont
été tournées et 40 montait sur la
première salle de tournage très bien
mais ce qui est dommage l'aller ce que
tu disais c'est que sur la version
américaine
il n'y a pas la même mécanique c'est à
dire que cette mécanique un peu à la
ferme
clues était mise pour la france et ça
c'est dommage ça du coup ce que disait
magali cclat julien courbet est un peu
là sophie davant de france 2 où il est
l'homme dans une pièce avec le candidat
entre guillemets qui l'a et
l'entrepreneur et puis après ils passent
à la pièce suivante
enex c'est vrai que c'est vraiment
dommage que julien c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui s'investit les noms on va
regarder juste le bas ce que fais je
garde mon programme c'est vrai qu'il est
là au début de l'opération et après il
disparaît mais je pense que c'est une
volonté de sa part la star du programme
ce sont les investisseurs d'accra
forcément là les autres prenaient la
mesure d'un mister entrepreneurs bonjour
midi pour chanter si vous êtes ça c'est
parce que vous avez une super idée de
nous proposer exactement pour la
développer vous pensez à vos enfants et
votre femme qui au regard des sons qui
voit de faire de bien sûr ah bah si je
travaille aujourd'hui c'est pour eux
molcho merci c'est maintenant que tout
se joue pour vous merci quand vous avez
ressenti ce moment un peu déçu forcément
ok lloris n a en rien ébranlé votre
confiance avait coûté un jour ou l'autre
je suis certain je me brosse les dents
et votre produit ou encore hull pour la
suite et bravo
déjà bravo parce que je suis un fan de
pétanque ont trouvé l'idée
extraordinaire qu'est ce que vous
ressentez c'est un peu de déception là
franchement si on avait demandé un
rendez-vous on n'aurait pas eu là on a
eu cinq rendez vous d'un coup et on a
gagné des années donc tant mieux
bonne chance pour la suite et à bientôt
sur un terrain de boules a fait les cons
ça fait la marque de démission et donc
il ya un truc qui est super important
chez julien courbet c'est que c'est un
contrat confiance c'est à dire que quand
les téléspectateurs y tombe sur julien
courbet et dit mince je peux avoir
confiance dans ce programme on va pas me
raconter n'importe quoi
il dégage ça de par les émissions qui
n'a fait avant 34 voilà ce petit en bref
une version mais ça crédibilise le
programme et on vient se fait pas
entourlouper et avoir un prénom date
heure juste pour six minutes c'est
important rim pour vendre le programme
s'il y avait juste les membres du jury
au vis-à-vis de la presse ça aurait été
compliqué là est à la figure gn urbaine
cas l'expérience julien courbet et les
gens ont un sentiment de curiosité pour
le regarde et fidéliser un programme en
tout cas on va sur évolution peut-être
ça va monter on est un des rares pays où
ça ne fonctionne pas ça marche partout
dans le monde mais pas j'ai nommé non la
saison en angleterre on n'a pas vraiment
la même culture de la feuille où le
vocabulaire start up
ça fait un peu juste pour l'anecdote
c'est que les sites internet des
entrepreneurs ont carrément sauté
pendant l'hymne normal parce qu'il ya un
trafic c'est vous avez rêvé n'oublions
pas que ces 16 minutes en prime time sur
une grande chaîne quoi qu'il arrive pour
eux c'est un vrai à une vraie chance et
un vrai crack